hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
today we're doing the q a video for idea
number 16
which is gravity i have to look it up i
always forget what number it is
idea number 16 was gravity which of
course we used as a dis
excuse to talk about general relativity
einstein's wonderful theory of curved
space time and why that leads us to
gravity
so for the q a video we got a bunch of
good questions but there's also some
things i wanted to fit in
and didn't fit into the already
enormously bloated and long
gravity main video so i'm going to
divide it up in the beginning here the q
a video i'm going to try to cover some
bases of the actual questions
cleaning up some of the conceptual
background for general relativity
and then we're going to skip ahead in
some sense to talk about
black holes in a little bit more detail
there's a whole bunch of things to say
obviously about black holes they're
interesting
and so i wanted to use the q a video
here as an excuse to do
that so for the actual questions where
do we start
uh let's start with the principle of
equivalence which of course was one of
the things we mentioned
as an inspiration for uh einstein
coming up with general relativity and we
talked about the principal equivalents
in terms of a small box we said
if you have a small region of space-time
like a box here you are
in the box and maybe you're on the earth
and you're being pulled down toward the
earth
or maybe you're just accelerating out in
space
rocket ship okay here you are and
you can't tell the difference inside the
box in a small region of space-time
if the engine is quiet and the
acceleration is uniform
you can't tell the difference there's a
lot of caveats there right and
people you know have questions about
these caveats they're like well
how small does the region of space time
have to be like could i measure the
gravity between the two forces are they
self-gravitating
could i measure the difference in
gravity from the top of the box to the
bottom of the box
so the point is you shouldn't i guess
what i want to say is you shouldn't take
this whole experiment too seriously
okay it's inspirational it is not
technical the principle of equivalence
is not a
deep down feature of reality what it was
was an idea that helped einstein invent
general relativity
general relativity is a deep down
feature of reality and you can show
in the context of general relativity
that something like the principle of
equivalence is
true but they're not separately true it
was it was something that was a building
block
uh it's like a step ladder you know or a
ladder you put on the top of the
building you put the ladder there you
climb to the top of the building
once you're on the top you can throw
away the ladder if that's where you want
to be is at the top of the building
so when we say things like um
the principle of equivalence holds true
in small regions of space time
that's sort of supposed to push you in
the direction of thinking that
in the limit as the region of space time
becomes
infinitesimally small these statements
become more
and more accurate okay that's the idea
we talked about how that is sort of
matching on to the idea in differential
geometry
that on a curved space time manifold the
metric the thing that describes the
actual geometry of space time
looks more and more like the geometry of
flat space time the so-called minkowski
space-time
metric so that's the spirit in which you
should be thinking about
the principle of equivalence it's not
something that is
is supposed to be rigorously defined all
on its own it's more inspirational
another thing like that by the way is
mock's principle
uh sort of like that but much worse
mock's principle i i to be honest have a
difficulty even
um stating it coherently because it
wasn't very coherent
but the idea behind mock's principle is
that
i can i just write down the ideas i
don't even know a picture to draw but
that inertial trajectories
which are special in relativity
they are well defined
are set somehow
by matter in the universe
the idea being look we mentioned whether
it's
uh newtonian physics or relativity
that there's no preferred location in
space right the laws of physics are the
same from place to place
and from time to time uh there's no
preferred velocity that's one of the
things if you forget about acceleration
for the moment
this uh thought experiment being in the
box and not being able to tell what's
going on
uh also applies to the question of at
what velocity
are you moving this would have been just
as true in galileo's time so it's
there's something called galilean
relativity
and of course einstein updates it for
lorenz invariants and things like that
but the basic idea is there is no
preferred speed there's no preferred
velocity there's no ether
filling all of space with respect to
which you can measure your velocity
by the way off footnote here very often
we discover something in the universe
whether it's quantum fields or the
classical electromagnetic field or dark
energy or something like that and people
say well isn't that just like the ether
no none of those things are like the
ether none of those things
define a rest frame the whole point
of the ether was to say here's my
velocity with respect to the ether
and then they went through long
elaborate reasons to show that you
couldn't actually
measure your velocity with respect to
the ether and finally einstein said well
in that case you don't need the ether at
all and he got rid of it
but something like quantum fields or the
quantum vacuum or the energy density of
the quantum vacuum none of those things
are things that you can measure your
rest frame with respect to there's no
preferred velocity
so they're not really like the ether
anyway um
we mentioned way back when when we talk
about action and forces and things like
that
it's interesting provocative i don't
know what you want to say
curious that there is no preferred place
in the universe no preferred location
no preferred velocity but there is a
preferred acceleration
right there are some trajectories
some let's say this way there are
trajectories of constant acceleration
and some of them are different than
others they're all noticeable you can
tell
in this box whether you are accelerated
or not okay and you can certainly tell
whether you were on an unaccelerated
trajectory which is an inertial
trajectory and so mock's principle ernst
mock was a famous
very uh big wig uh german physicist and
philosopher at the time
and he you know he was sort of
charmingly wrong about a lot of things
he very famously
didn't believe in the existence of atoms
so he
uh was sort of boltzmann's nemesis
because boltzmann was another famous
german physicist at the time austrian
but moved to germany
um and boltzmann's whole career was
built on the existence of adams and
and you know boltzmann could visit
england and they loved him because they
were all about the atoms because they
had maxwell and thompson and dalton and
so forth there
then he would go home to germany and no
one would believe him anymore and he
felt very sad about that
anyway mock's principle says the reason
why
there are certain trajectories that are
preferred as inertial as zero
acceleration
is because they are measured with
respect to
their acceleration is measured with
respect to matter scattered throughout
all the universe so somehow there was a
dynamical
physical reason why certain trajectories
were inertial were
special and einstein was very inspired
by this and this is something that
einstein really thought a lot about
and it helped him sort of perceive the
idea
of the metric as a dynamical field that
has its own
equations of motion and the metric of
space time itself would respond to
matter and energy
so there's no question historically that
mock's principle
played a major role in the development
of general relativity
the problem is mark's principle is not
true
once you have general relativity it's
just not true that inertial trajectories
have
anything to do well anything to do is
too strong it's just not true that
inertial trajectories are determined by
matter in the universe the most obvious
example of this
is that minkowski space is a solution to
einstein's equations in general
relativity
empty space with no matter in it is a
perfectly good solution to general
relativity
and there are certainly inertial
trajectories in minkowski space we can
tell
whether a trajectory in minkowski space
is being accelerated or not
um nevertheless there's there is of
course in general relativity the fact
that matter
scattered throughout the universe can
affect trajectories in some way it
doesn't set what trajectories are
initial and what are not
but matter far away can you know push
and pull things that eventually
affects trajectories nearby and for
decades now for a hundred years now
people have tried to make this feature
of general relativity
somehow map on to mock's principle but
it just doesn't it's just
false it was just a mistake it was it
was a good idea that didn't quite work
out
one of the things i say is that for my
uh textbook space time and geometry i
was very proud this was one of the first
maybe the only major textbook in general
relativity to not even mention
box principle at all okay it's just it's
not any it's not important anymore sorry
about that so
trying to see how mark's principle can
be satisfied is not something that i
would uh put a lot of work into
final note on on this kind of thing is
that
these inertial trajectories in gr
in general relativity as we say uh
inertial trajectories
or geodesics so
inertial trajectories are still special
in general relativity just like they are
in special relativity
but they have a slightly different
character so geodesics are
that's not geodesics geo
desiccs geodesics are the extremal paths
right the extremal length
paths so space-time diagram
space time uh maybe things are going on
here this is not necessarily mikowski
space maybe it's some curve space time
of some
of some sort if you start here and end
there and you have a path that connects
them and you want to say is this an
actual path that a free particle
can take well then you calculate the
length of the path
in fact if this path is time-like you
calculate the time along the path
and you extremize along all the possible
paths
what that time actually is and i say
extremize because in relativity
the physical paths will actually
maximize the amount of time the amount
of clicks on an actual wristwatch
that moves along that trajectory thus
the twin paradox as we talked about
so there are still inertial trajectories
in general relativity
um they just can be what might look like
curved to someone standing outside so
someone i think asked about you know the
earth moving around the sun
i tried to explain this in the original
video but but it is a little unfamiliar
so it's worth saying again
the earth orbiting the sun is doing its
best to move on a straight line
okay it is the straightest possible line
it can go on
and i know that's counterintuitive
because it's clearly moving
like wouldn't a real straight line be
straighter than this ellipse that the
earth does around the sun
and the answer is no that would not be
as straight a line
in space-time so when you draw that
ellipse
of the earth moving around the sun
you're drawing a trajectory in space
you're ignoring space-time and most of
the earth's motion is in time not in
space because it's moving way slower
than the speed of light right
so the path that is actually followed by
the earth which is pretty much a test
particle
for these purposes is actually an
extremal
path a geodesic in the curved space-time
caused by the sun that's one thing i
wanted to say the other thing is people
are asking about um since we were
talking about the equivalence principle
what about the connection between
inertial mass and gravitational mass
in newtonian gravity right you have
these two different things you have
inertial mass
which just shows up in newtonian
mechanics
in the equation f equals m a so call
that the inertial mass
so the inertial mass is the constant of
proportionality
that relates the force acting on a body
to how much it accelerates by
right you might think that this is an
intrinsic feature of the object it's
inertia
right the amount of mass it has inertia
wise but then there's also the
gravitational mass
which is how much a body is
is affected by gravity right so
the force due to gravity is
g newton's constant m1
m2 over r squared and these masses
are the gravitational off of a body
right
in some sense they're equivalent to the
electric charge they're the amount of
they're proportional to how much
gravitational field the body creates
and how much it's affected by the
gravitational field
so conceptually you could imagine these
two things are different you could
imagine a world
in which objects had a different
gravitational charge
than their inertial mass and newton said
hey you know in in reality these two
things seem to be equal
that's why objects can fall at the same
rate right otherwise objects
would have different gravitational
charges and they would not fall at the
same rate
but he didn't know why and so he said
you know this is an interesting feature
right
so it's part of the principle of
equivalence the
equality between inertial and
gravitational masses is subsumed by the
principle of equivalence
if inertial and gravitational masses
were not the same
then you could in fact drop objects with
different gravitational masses or
different ratios
of gravitational mass to inertial mass
you could drop them in the box
and measure whether or not you were in a
gravitational field so the fact that the
principle equivalence is good implies
that also in general relativity
inertial mass is equal to gravitational
mass but like i said
the principle of equivalence is not you
know by itself
right it's an inspiration for general
relativity the better way to say it is
that once you have general relativity
it just follows that the inertial mass
is proportional to the gravitational
mass and the reason why
is because the source of gravity is the
energy or the mass of things right
equals mc squared so
relativity wise these things are
interchangeable or at least comparable
gravity is sourced by mass the inertial
mass of whatever you want to call
there's no separate thing there's
something called the mass
and that both affects the equations of
motion for things and
is the source of gravity and that just
falls out of how you derive
einstein's equations for example from
the einstein-hilbert action
lagrangian that we talked about so it's
a consequence
of that and so that's how it should work
right once you understand things better
you have a more comprehensive framework
once you understand what general
relativity is
then you can just show oh yes this thing
that you might call the inertial mass
and the gravitational mass in the
newtonian limit
they're going to work out to be the same
okay
um good so that was one set of questions
the other set of questions before we get
into the black holes
was dealt with singularities
and perfectly legitimate to be asking
these questions you know i mentioned
them very quickly and then sort of
breezed on by them so in the context for
example i drew a picture
like this remember the kruskal diagram
kruskal is a mathematician who invented
a certain set of coordinates that you
can use in general relativity to
describe
black holes and the nice thing about
these coordinates
is that even though space time is curved
this is these are coordinates that make
sense for
a short shield black hole so just a
black hole with no nothing
inside or outside just a black hole all
by itself a pure pristine black hole you
can modify them for more general
circumstances but that's where they're
most useful
so a kruskal coordinate black hole
black holes don't care about coordinates
but a black hole in classical
coordinates
has the feature that the light cones are
still at 45 degrees
so the light cones don't tilt over like
one of the diagrams i drew
the black hole kind of look like a
cylinder with event horizon going upward
and the light cones tilt over so once
you go in you can't come back out
the crustal coordinates also um
convey what's going on inside the black
hole
but they do so in a way here is r the
radial distance away from the black hole
and they do so in such a way that at any
point the light cones look like this
that was a pretty shaky line you're
gonna think i'm getting old i'm just
trying to get
be cautious uh the light cones still
look like 45 degrees
everywhere and that's very helpful
feature because you can sort of
instantly see just by looking at what's
going on in the diagram
how you're moving are you moving forward
in time are you moving space like or
whatever
and in the kruskal diagram the event
horizon
which itself is null light moves along
the event horizon
okay is at this 45 degree angle so this
is
the surface r equals two
g m so i call that little r that was a
bad idea i shouldn't have called that
little r let's call it capital r because
i'm not using regular
short shield coordinates i'm using cross
coordinates and this is capital t
up here and then so there's a
relationship between
crustal coordinates capital r capital t
or let's do it the other way around
because you're used to seeing time first
right
so crustal coordinates call it capital t
capital r
and then the short shield coordinates
which we're more used to are little t
little r
okay so and then it turns out that the
singularity
looks like this so this is r
equals zero the singularity inside the
black hole okay
um the one and so here it is clear that
there's
the time and space do not convert into
each other when you are inside
the event horizon some people still say
that some grown-up physicists say that
time and space turn into each other
that's crazy talk
what happens if you're here you are and
you fall into the black hole
you go like that you just move forward
in time
but the time coordinates the
schwarzschild coordinates
flip their nature so the t the short
shield coordinate becomes a space like
coordinate
and r the schwarzschild coordinate
becomes a timeline coordinate but who
cares no one cares what the coordinates
do
time and space are still time and space
even inside the black hole event horizon
the point is that the singularity the
the point of infinite curvature is in
your future that's their true
physical point um so what i wanted to
get to was the fact that
there in some sense both r equals 0
and r equals 2 gm are singularities but
in a very very different sense
so r equals 2g m which is where the
event horizon is
is a coordinate singularity
i'll write the whole word out there you
go coordinate singularity
and what that means is simply you have
chosen bad coordinates
so certain coordinate uh components
so let's put it this way remember when
we wrote out the metric
you know 1 minus 2g m over r et cetera
certain components of the metric will
blow up or go to zero
in these coordinates and when you have a
coordinate singularity you are very
uh it's perfectly okay to worry that
something physical is going on
but it is not at all clear that anything
important is going on
at that point you may just have chosen
bad coordinates right
this is something even einstein really
struggled with for years and years like
coordinates are not that big a deal the
a lot of the development of general
relativity the general relativity really
sort of came to life in the 1960s you
know einstein and his friends worked on
it for
many years after he invented it but uh
progress was slow and a lot of it
because there was a lot of new data
right you weren't discovering
gravitational waves or quasars or
anything like that
in the 60s we started really getting in
data that pushed people to think about
gender relativity in a more careful way
and geniuses like roger penrose and
stephen hawking you know took up the
challenge and did a great job at that
and so this idea that we could
understand space times without relying
on coordinates
was one of the important things to come
out of that revolution in general
relativity in the 1960s
so there's no nothing really bad about
the event arise and you wouldn't even
notice right this is the thing you're
always told
if you fall into the event horizon of a
big black hole there's no signpost there
at the horizon you would pass right
through without even knowing
whereas r equals zero is a
let's put the little arrows here is a
curvature singularity
by which we mean if you i should
not talk and write there we go
by which we mean that you can calculate
scalar quantities okay a scalar quantity
means
not a quantity that depends in any way
on the coordinates
right just a function of space-time and
you can calculate
scalar quantities and they go to
infinity
so there's a at the curve for
singularity so there's a true sense
in which the curvature is becoming
infinite at the curvature singularity
uh but that sounds a little haphazard i
mean
some curvature scalers that you could
calculate
don't go to zero at the curvature
singularity so a whole
you know subfield of general relativity
arose in which what you
do is figure out whether or not
something really is a singularity
a true curvature singularity in some
sense of the word what is the once and
for all
set of criteria for whether or not as
you approach something
some region or some point in the
manifold in general relativity
you're really hitting a singularity and
the answer is it's really complicated
i i i met this guy chris clark who is a
professional general relativist who
wrote a whole book
called singularities in general
relativity and i was a young student at
the time and i said well that sounds
interesting should i buy your book and
read it and he says no
it's not really worth it like unless you
really want to study nothing but
singularities and general relativity
there's an enormous amount of technical
apparatus that goes into
kind of a tiny amount of payoff
relatively speaking unless like i said
singularities and general relativity are
your thing okay
um and you know just to be clear at the
singularity r equals zero
uh what happens you know if you if you
fall into there this person falling in
is gonna die
right you're spaghettified you're torn
apart uh you're spaghettified because
the tidal forces due to gravity are
stronger in some
directions they pull you apart in one
direction and squish you together in
another direction
tidal forces um so you know it's it's
going to be bad
but the actual point r equals zero
what we say is the following you
shouldn't include that point r equals
zero
in your definition of the space-time
manifold that point or in this case as
you see
it's a space-like surface right it's not
really a point so singularity even if
its coordinates are
r equals zero that's not enough to say
that it's a point in space
here very clearly this particular
singularity
is a surface in space-time it's a
space-like surface
and so what you say is that you should
just remove that from your definition
of space-time and if you're really
honest what you say is we have no idea
what happens there in the real world
because the curvature there is so large
there's zero reason to believe that
classical general relativity is accurate
when you approach a space-time
singularity
we know there's something called quantum
mechanics we know that classical general
relativity does not include quantum
mechanics
when the curvature is so large that it
is you know the
distance over which the curvature
changes is smaller than the planck
length
then we think we believe have every
reason to believe that quantum mechanics
becomes really really important so what
classical general relativity has to say
about singularities is irrelevant
class is physically irrelevant it might
be intellectually interesting
but has nothing to do with what happens
in the real world so
provisionally what we say is if you hit
a singularity in classical general
relativity you stop
counting space time and that is really
the end space time ends
but you also admit that in the real
world something different could be going
on
so in the real world could you you know
make a wormhole or pop out a baby
universe inside a black hole
the only honest thing to say is we don't
know right we don't have the theory of
quantum gravity figured out well enough
to answer questions like that right now
so until we do we say space time ends at
the singularity and exactly the same
thing is true in the big bang big bang
is a singularity in the past
uh t equals zero rather than r equals
zero in the expanding universe metric
what can we say you know you can say
well it's the edge of space-time
according to classical general
relativity but then you should
immediately say and we all know that's
not right that's not the final story
so all we can say is we don't know what
happens there could be space time
earlier than the big bang or maybe
there's not
we just don't know all right
now i was trying to draw this crosstalk
diagram carefully but i'm going to
redraw it again because
the next thing i want to get to i want
to start talking about black holes
a little bit more carefully so there was
a good question
about time symmetry in black holes
after all um if you look at this picture
you fall into the black hole and it
looks like
you fall in and you can't get out in
other words
you enter toward the future and then
something is true about you now that was
not true about you in the past
but wasn't it true that all the laws of
physics including laws of general
relativity
are invariant under time reversal like
how did that
one wayness come about why is it you can
go in but can't go out toward the future
like
if you ran the movie backward you see
someone being spit out from a black hole
so what's going on there
so that's a fascinating question and one
way of answering it is
to take this remember this is this is
this picture
is supposed to be what i really should
do you know what
what i did secretly i didn't tell you
this uh in the original video
for gravity but what i did was i drew
this as a radial coordinate so i started
at capital r equals zero right so i do
this like as
as if you're drawing something in polar
coordinates just an ordinary space time
start at zero and get only positive
values for the radial coordinate
but einstein and rosen who actually
studied this
realized that and of course kruskal
studied it also and others
realized that you could actually extend
this
space-time metric through r equals zero
to negative values of r
there's nothing special that happened uh
the space does not go to zero volume
right i mean
r equals two g m little r equals two g m
is oops trying to draw here
this point at what looks like the origin
of coordinates
is that little r the schwarzschild
coordinate equals r to gm
it's a sphere of area
you know uh what is the area of a sphere
four pi r squared okay right um it's not
a point
in space time and so you could ask like
can i go through it
can i go to the other side and the
answer turns out to be yes
so the full kruskal diagram
looks like this it looks like what i
almost drew
up there but basically you can just
extend
what's going on in the universe to a
whole new region
and so here is capital r
capital t there is a singularity here so
there's no space time here that's
excluded
but there's a whole other universe on
the other side there are people who
could live here
and there's a singularity in the past
over here so this is the
maximally extended short shield solution
and if i took a slice through it
so let me let me take a slice that just
goes like this
okay a space-like slice and i asked what
is the geometry of that space like slice
well out here very far um out here
right far away i'm far away from the
black hole it looks like empty space so
just like looks like flat space
so let me draw that here's flat space
okay but as i go in it become it begins
curling
curving and then it curves and as i go
over here
to this side well then i get far away
from the black hole again and it looks
like
another copy of empty space
and these two copies of empty space are
connected
by what we call a wormhole or an
einstein-rosen
bridge okay so this i really should
to be slightly more evocative i should
oops i should turn this on its side what
are the chances i can do this
yeah there we go not the best drawing
but you get the point
so this is that yellow line
has the geometry that i represented in
this picture over here
so the fully maximally extended
kruskal diagram short field solution
describes not one but two copies of
asymptotically flat space-time
connected by a wormhole and with a black
hole in between if you do something
terrible notice you can't get from one
side to the other so if you try
here you are so you're a
astronaut in your rocket ship and you're
going to try to get from this region
to that region but you notice that you
can't go faster than the speed of light
so instead you will always hit the
singularity and die
you can't actually cross this bridge
this einstein-rosen bridge
it's what we call a non-traversable
wormhole
okay but what you also notice let me
undo that because it's cluttering up the
diagram
um but you also notice
is that the whole diagram is symmetric
with respect to time
right there's something in the top half
of the diagram and the mirror image in
the bottom half of the diagram
so this is this region here actually
let's do it
yet another color okay green perhaps
so this region here
is what we would call the black hole
whereas
this region here
guess what the white hole
the white hole is the time reverse of a
black hole
and it has the feature that things can
come out
of the event horizon from the white hole
to the outside world
but things can't go in because the event
horizon is separating
the singularity from the rest of the
world in the opposite sense okay
so a white hole is nothing more than a
black hole
played backward in time and so
yes it is true that the black hole
violates time symmetry violates time
reversal symmetry it's something that is
in the future and not in the past
but that's also because a black hole is
only part of the story in the full
maximally symmetric maximally extended
short shield solution
you have both a black hole and a white
hole and the whole shebang
is completely symmetric with respect to
time now having said that
we have no reason to think that white
holes exist in the real world remember
this is a
thought experiment where you take
einstein's equation with literally
zero matter anywhere and you ask what is
the solution that is spherically
symmetric and i extend it all over
the world but that's not what you
actually expect in the real world you
expect there to be matter
so if we do a slightly more realistic
plot where we have something like again
r and t okay but now we put matter in
there
so now our capital r equals zero really
is
the center of everything at least to
start so we put you know
some stuff this is a star
then the star collapses so what happens
is the star shrinks to zero
this is the matter inside the star and
at some point an event horizon forms
and this is little r equals 2gm and now
you have a black hole
inside here okay this is a much more
realistic
space-time diagram for what it looks
like when you make a black hole
so in the real world you don't get this
funky thing with a wormhole
and a past white hole and anything like
that you have a star
it collapses you make a black hole and
it's time asymmetric because your ending
point is different than your beginning
point that's not surprising
at all okay so that was a very good
question about time symmetry good good
catch there but
uh these are all we have to distinguish
between
in principle mathematical solutions to
einstein's equations like this maximally
symmetric thing with a
maximally extended thing with the
wormhole etc versus what is likely to
happen
in the real world where we have an arrow
of time and cosmology and all those
other things
okay but there's more i want to say
about black holes
so let's dig in a little more to black
holes and some of their features
again we could go on for hours you could
easily have a 24 uh video course just
about
black holes right but we have to be
superficial because
time is of the essence um so i'm just
going to mention some interesting facts
one fact is they have no hair
which is john wheeler's colorful way of
saying that black holes
are characterized by their mass their
charge
and their spin and that's it
i mean a planet or a star also has mass
it also has electric charge
charge could be zero probably is zero if
you have an
astronomical body with a lot of electric
charge
it just rips the opposite charge from
the plasma around it and quickly
neutralizes
that's just as true for black holes as
it would be for planets or stars so
in real astrophysical black holes the
charge is usually zero
um but yeah like planets or stars black
holes can also
spin and we do expect that black holes
do spin
in fact what we've seen in the universe
and the evidence we have for black holes
and galaxies and binary star systems
is that black holes tend to spin very
very fast so spinning black holes are
very very astrophysically relevant
so you might say what's the big deal i
mean planets and stars have mass charge
and spin
so do black holes why is this surprising
that the point of cosmic
sorry this is not cosmic no hair this is
just black black holes have no hair
all right now i have to admit there is a
equivalent or at least
analogous um conjecture theorem in
cosmology
that the universe has no hair if the
universe has a non-zero vacuum energy a
cosmological constant okay
then the universe sort of eventually
approaches empty space with nothing but
cosmological constant in it
so the universe has no hair either
that's called cosmic no hair
this is just black hole no hair and the
point here is that
even though a star or a planet has mass
charge and spin they have other things
as well
if you take a picture of jupiter or
venus
or the earth they all look different
right they have topography they have
lumps on them there's oceans in some
places and planet
and continents in other places black
holes
don't have any of that stuff the number
of numbers
that you would need to completely
specify the earth
what's going on on the earth i mean the
earth has people on it and plants and a
whole bunch of things to completely
specify the earth
we would require an enormous amount of
information
whereas when you have a black hole to
completely 100
specify it you need to give me three
numbers
it's mass it's charge and it's spin
that's an amazing fact
um and it's a theorem i mean you
obviously to prove these theorems you
have to make certain assumptions
uh that's what people do in general
relativity but this is part of the
excitement in the 60s and 70s
people were proving theorems like this
so black holes have no hair they're all
very very simple
um second thing which actually has not
quite been proven although there's very
good reason to think it's true is cosmic
censorship
censorship
so this says that singularities
are not naked by which we mean
singularities
are hidden behind
horizons
so we saw that in the picture
the pictures that we drew so there's a
singularity at r equals 2 gm
here's the singularity right here and it
is
behind this black hole event horizon
here's a white hole there's a
singularity again but it is behind
this horizon and so you never get a
space-time diagram according to the
cosmic censorship conjecture because we
haven't completely proven it
we've proven it in certain special cases
according to cosmic censorship
every singularity is separated from the
wider world
by an event horizon is hidden behind an
event horizon
um that's interesting it's it's
important for various uh
features of general relativity such as
you know predictability right
we said that once you hit a singularity
all bets are off the theory is broken
down you don't know what happens next
so if you had a naked singularity as
it's called just out there in the world
that you could easily reach poke at and
then walk away from
you wouldn't be able to use the
equations of general relativity to
predict
what was going to happen when that
occurred so to get general relativity to
be predictable you can hide all that
mess
behind an event horizon and then you say
well okay i can predict what's going to
go on outside the event horizon anyway
so that's the cosmic censorship
conjecture
finally final fact not a final fact but
last fact in this little three item list
is the area theorem
i think this was hawking to prove this
the area theorem says that the area of
an event horizon or collection of event
horizons
only increases over time now this is
uh there's a clearly an arrow of time
built in here also so we're talking
about event horizons in the future we're
putting narrow time in
by not allowing for any white holes in
our past but
the the area of all the event horizons
only increases with time so this is the
time derivative of the total area of all
the event horizons goes up
uh so why is that a thing so i mean
this makes intuitive sense in the
following sense if you have a single
black hole
you can throw things into it increase
its mass and its area
goes up right the area of an ordinary
short shell black hole
is proportional to its mass squared
because it's proportional to the
radius squared and the radius is
proportional to the mass the radius is
2gm um
short shield radius 2gm
for a short shield black hole for a
non-spinning black hole so
sure if you have one black hole just
sitting there i can easily throw mass
into it and the area goes up
and then that makes sense the area goes
up i cannot throw
negative mass into it so one of the
assumptions of a theorem like this is
there are no negative mass particles in
nature that i can throw into the black
hole
okay but you might say well why do we
say the area of the horizon rather than
the mass
of the black hole right i mean by the
same logic
i can only increase the mass of a black
hole not decrease it
it turns out that's not true uh for
fascinating reasons due to roger penrose
remember
the cosby no hair theorem says that
there's mass there's charge but who
cares
and there's also spin okay and
when you have a spinning black hole the
area of the event horizon depends on
both the mass
and the spin basically the spinning
black hole becomes oblate like
like a flattened pancake if it spins
very very fast it's not a perfectly
round
sphere anymore so this simple formula
area goes like mass squared is no longer
true for a spinning black hole there's a
more complicated formula
and it turns out that when you have a
rapidly spinning black hole
you can decrease its mass by a little
bit
you can by something called the penrose
process you can throw matter
into the black hole uh sorry not into
into his an exaggeration
you can throw matter very close to the
black hole have it split apart
so that some of it escapes to the
outside world and some of it falls in
such that the stuff that comes out has
more energy than the original thing you
threw in
so let's let me just i need to show you
a picture here so
the picture here here's a top view of a
spinning black hole
okay so here's the black hole
it's spinning let's imagine it has some
spin in this direction
there's a region outside but not very
very far outside
looks like a smiley face um called the
ergosphere
sphere top view so this is the axis
along which it's spinning is pointing at
us
and what you can do is this you can take
some
two objects glued together but maybe
there's like
some little latch or some spring or some
explosive device that can separate them
at the right moment
you can throw them in exactly the right
way
into the ergosphere but not into the
black hole so don't let them cross the
event horizon
and then split them apart so that one of
them
falls into the black hole and the other
one goes zipping out
okay and penrose showed that the
energy here e final compared to e
initial can be greater
that is what he showed so basically and
what happens when you do that is the
black hole slows down
and it's spinning so basically you're
extracting spin from the black hole
and the total energy of the black hole
also goes down at the same time
okay so if you read the there's a
massive textbook
by misner thorne and wheeler called
gravitation and they
describe an elaborate scenario where you
know super intelligent civilization
could
power its energy needs from spinning
black holes and you know according to
the laws of physics that is entirely
allowed
it might be not very feasible it may be
dangerous but it is allowed there's a
lot of energy locked up there that you
can get out
so it is not true that the mass of a
black hole
can only go up can't go down but when
you go through the formula for the area
the area of the black hole does always
go up even during the penrose process
if you have two smaller black holes and
combine them together to make one bigger
one
the area of the big black hole is bigger
than
the sum of the two areas of the two
smaller black holes so the area theorem
says the
area always goes up now
look you you must be thinking when i
draw something like this when i write
this equation right the area
uh only goes up over time this does
violate time reversal and variance right
i mean this does
uh require some kind of arrow of time
and i justified it by saying there's no
white holes in the past etc
but still there's another famous
equation
that kind of looks like that right
there's the second law of thermodynamics
second law of thermodynamics
that the entropy total entropy of
everything
only increases over time i should say uh
yeah greater than or equal to zero right
now those two equations are both very
very simple but they do have a family
resemblance to each other right
and it turns out that the other laws of
thermodynamics
uh conservation of energy and you know
thermal equilibrium things like that
all of those laws of thermodynamics have
analogs
in the laws of black holes classical
black holes right there's no
nothing statistical here like this area
theorem is not like
entropy or thermodynamics where you have
a bunch of little particles moving
around and the collective behavior
is what you're looking at you're just
doing classical general relativity and
you get this as an exact result
so hawking and brandon carter
and others published the laws of black
hole mechanics they had this elaborate
analogy between black holes and
thermodynamics and then jacob
beckenstein came along and said well
maybe it's not just an analogy maybe
black holes have entropy
and maybe the entropy is
proportional to the area of the event
horizon
and maybe there is a generalized
second law he only said this later but
that's okay we're not going in
historical order
that says that the sum
of the area of the black holes
plus the entropy of matter
increases over time the generalized
second law of thermodynamics maybe they
should just be combined together
hawking was very annoyed by this uh one
of the reasons why
he was annoyed is because he understood
thermodynamics well enough to know that
you can also think of entropy as
relating energy and temperature
in a certain way and so if you really
thought that a black hole had
entropy and it really you know the area
of the event horizon really
was like the entropy then just like a
thermodynamic black body giving off
radiation
black holes should give off radiation
and
they're black you can't say that black
holes give off radiation so he went and
tried to prove the black holes do not
give off radiation and he ended up
proving that black holes
do give off radiation so what we got at
the end of this
little drama was beckenstein
let's see if i installed beckenstein's
name correctly
beckenstein hawking
entropy because it was really
beckenstein's idea
that black holes have entropy really
even though that hockey anothers had the
formal um analogy and then hawking
really
sealed the deal and i'll explain how he
did that
and there's a formula for it let me see
if i can get the formula right i'm not
gonna get the formula right
uh well i'll get it right but i'll not
fill in a lot of details the entropy of
a black hole
is the area in plunk units
so you know the plunk length which
formula for which i do not remember
that's why i'm not going to get all the
details right here
um you take the area in plunk units so
you have the plunk length squared is one
plunk unit of area
and then you divide by four that's all
you got to do and that is the entropy
the entropy
these are units where not only
is h-bar equals c equals one but also
boltzmann's constant k is set equal to
one boltzmann's constant converts
entropies into natural numbers
okay so the area measured in planck
units
uh or let me let's put it this way we
can do it make it be a little bit
prettier
okay the area the black hole event
horizon
over four times the plunk length squared
there you go that's all the details are
there um
except k is set equal to one okay and
that is according to beckenstein hawking
that
is the entropy of a black hole and
it's an enormous number if you plug in
the numbers for realistic black holes
let's see what i got here
uh 4 times 10 to the 77
times the mass of the black hole divided
by the mass of the sun
squared so a single black hole
with the mass of the sun would have an
entropy of 4 times 10 to the 77 which is
a really big number
uh a black hole the center of our galaxy
with more than a million times the mass
of the sun
has a an entropy over 10 to the 90th
which is more than the entropy of all of
the photons and ordinary particles in
the entire observable universe
so black holes have an enormous amount
of entropy
and what hawking also showed and
beckenstein didn't quite go this far
is that black holes do give off
radiation and so they have a temperature
and this was hawking's formula i believe
one of these you know he has a
not a grave but he has a memorial in
winchester cathedral and i think the
entropy formula is on there but maybe
it's the temperature formula
uh the temperature i did write this down
no one in their right mind would ever
remember this but
h bar c cubed
over 8 pi g which is newton's constant
k boltzmann's constant m the mass of the
black hole
which for solar mass black hole works
out to be really really cold
six times ten to the minus six
mass of the sun divided by the mass of
the black hole
kelvin right so kelvin is the scale of
absolute temperature where
zero kelvin is literal bottom of the
temperature scale
so 10 to the minus six kelvin is cold
like the cosmic microwave background
that suffuses all of interstellar space
is about 3 kelvin
this is 6 millionths of a kelvin
okay so this is very very cold for a one
solar mass black hole
and as the mass goes up the temperature
goes down
so some people say will we ever be able
to observe hawking radiation from a
black hole
it's very possible the answer is no
because black holes that are
astrophysically
sized just have a very very cold
temperature the background radiation
of the universe completely swamps it by
an enormous amount
the only hope you would have is be being
able to find a really tiny black hole
and we don't know how to make those
right
you know how to make a black hole from a
star collapsing but you don't know how
to make a black
hole that is like you know a few grams
across
that would have a serious temperature we
don't know how to get them maybe there's
some left over from the early universe
from the big bang but no one really
knows
and then what this implies is that the
black holes give off radiation
and they lose mass right and therefore
if the black hole's not spinning its
area will go down
uh and in fact this whole thing happens
in a finite time so there's a lifetime
for black holes and the lifetime is
call it tau i don't know it just made it
up um
i'm not even giving you the equation for
it but for a solar mass black hole
2 times 10 to the 67 okay
times the mass of the black hole in
units of the mass of the sun cubed
years it's a very long time the
current age of the universe is something
like 10 to the 10 years
yeah 10 to the 10 years right so if you
get a solar mass black hole it will take
two
2 times 10 to the 67 years to evaporate
away
much much longer than the current age of
the universe because it's so cold
right the temperature will increase as
the black hole shrinks
but for the very long portion of the
black hole's lifetime it's just really
really cold
barely radiating at all one way of
thinking about this is that the typical
wavelength of a photon being given off
by the black hole is aborted the short
shield radius so for a big astrophysical
black hole these photons being given off
are very very low energy per photon
now you might worry because i said there
was something called an area theorems
that the area
goes up and down here i said but wait
hawking says that black holes give off
radiation and the area goes down
what's going on well the answer is the
area theorem is not true
area theorem is a feature of classical
general relativity
and hawking used quantum mechanics to
derive the existence of his radiation so
what becomes true
is the generalized second law so this is
true
even when black holes evaporate the area
of the event horizon can shrink
but it's only by giving off a lot of
photons that that happens and those
photons have entropy
so basically the black holes are
converting their entropy
into the entropy of the gas around them
then you can calculate you can compare
the entropy of the photons i said gas
but i'm in a gas of photons if you're
willing to believe in that
you can compare the entropy of the
photons and other particles
to the entropy of the black hole and it
is bigger you increase the entropy of
the universe by letting the black hole
evaporate
so everything is okay you know it all
fits together to get this to get all
i mean this is just very beautiful and
why did i
save this for the q a video um
you know i had this rule for the actual
videos biggest ideas in the universe
that we're talking about ideas that we
have very very good reason to believe
are true
i'm not getting into all different sorts
of speculation because then you know i
have my favorite kinds of speculation
other people have their own kinds of
speculation so we're not talking
in these videos a lot about the
multiverse
or inflation or you know your particular
grand unified theory or dark matter or
any of these things i mean dark matter
exists but which one which candidate it
is
we don't know so i don't want to get
into all the different candidates and
things like that
hawking radiation is in this funny
in-between
um space almost no one doubts that it is
real
because it's much like the graviton it's
not quite as as
well established as the graviton but
gravitons were we haven't observed
directly individual gravitons and we may
never
because they so weakly interact but
they're absolutely consequences of the
very basic features
of quantum mechanics and general
relativity so
it's very hard to imagine wriggling out
of the implication that gravitons are
real the the metric in general activity
is a field
it has fluctuations it has to be
quantized there should be gravitons
that's basically it we've detected the
classical
gravitational waves it'd be very weird
if there were not a particle-like
excitation that we could observe in
principle
called the graviton so hawking radiation
which gives rise to this temperature and
this evaporation and this entropy um
is similar to that it's not quite as
well established because you know black
holes are not quite as well established
as
flat space through which a graviton
could travel but it
seems to be an almost inescapable
conclusion that black holes should give
off hawking radiation so
i want to get it mentioned but we
haven't observed it we might never
observe it we might we might not
uh but until we do you know the rules of
science say it's still speculative
okay even if everyone believes it it
still counts as a speculation
now like i said uh
hawking got this fact about temperature
by considering
quantum mechanics and here you know i
need to be a little bit careful about
how to
talk about this here's how here's one
way of talking about it remember i drew
the picture of the black hole
as a cylinder so if i use sort of
conventional coordinates
here's the event horizon of a black hole
the radial coordinate r this is
time going up like that and out here
the light cones look like this but on
the event horizon they look like this
and inside they look like this so
they're pointing towards r equals zero
which is the singularity that's the
singularity there
and what hawking said is what i should
do
is think about quantum field theory and
what i should actually do is think about
virtual particles so
let me back up because the reason i'm
hesitating to talk about this is because
of course
there's what hawking did which was a
very careful calculation
in the context of quantum field theory
then there's what hawking
said he did when he explained it to
people who didn't read the original
calculation right so if you read a brief
history of time
what hawking says is well you know in
empty space there are these quantum
fluctuations there are virtual particles
popping in and out of existence so
you could imagine now let's use a
different color for virtual
uh particle fluctuations uh you can
imagine you know
an electron and a positron popping
out of existence in empty space and this
is just sort of
part of the renormalization of the
vacuum we already talked about this
there are
confinement diagrams that just represent
what happens in empty space all by
itself
and the vocabulary hawking used is that
sometimes
near the event horizon you'll get these
particle anti-particle pairs
where one of them will cross the horizon
and the other one will not
and in that case the one that crosses
the horizon will fall in
and the one that escapes will escape to
infinity and you'll observe it
and that's the hawking radiation it
doesn't have to be electrons and
positrons in fact
since the temperature is so low what you
want is very very very low energy
particles and it's much easier to have
that be photons or gravitons
themselves so it's almost always photons
that come out
of the black holes and how it works
this is another tricky thing about
general relativity read my much longer
technical book if you want the details
but the energy of the in-going particle
turns out
from the point of view of an observer
very very far away
this has an energy less than zero so the
particle that comes out has an energy
greater than zero so the reason why
the hole is shrinking is because it is
absorbing
negative energy negative mass particles
that's why its mass is going down
now this is kind of hokey this whole
explanation because it really
is set in a language that takes a little
bit too literally the dynamical
fluctuation of virtual particles in
empty space as we
tried to explain in previous videos in
the big idea video about interactions
and findment diagrams
prime diagrams are a story if the black
hole weren't there
you could tell the story of virtual
particles popping in out of existence
but the quantum state of the vacuum
is actually perfectly stationary nothing
is changing over time nothing is
literally popping in and out of
existence
the real reason why these particles go
away has to do with the fact that once
you're in the presence of a black hole
you're not in the vacuum there's a
horizon there
there's no reason for the state to be
static and indeed the state the state is
not static the black hole evaporates
right you're not in a vacuum state
so you know there's different
justifications you can attach
to this fact but the equations back you
up okay in fact there's
by now by even by the 80s there were
multiple different ways
of deriving the fact that black holes
have a temperature and do radiate away
i just want to you know if you heard
what we said before about finding
diagrams just being a story and you also
heard
hawking's version of this story i just
want them you to be able to
reconcile those in your head hawking's
story is also just a story his equations
were something very different and a
little bit more
reliable and more difficult to argue
with
okay final part of this whole story um
is the information loss puzzle the info
loss puzzle
so the idea here is that
in quantum mechanics we have the
schrodinger equation right
h psi equals i
h bar d by dt
psi okay the time rate of change of the
quantum state
is proportional to the hamiltonian
acting on the quantum state
and this is the schrodinger equation and
it's perfectly deterministic
we'll talk more later about determinism
more generally but
this is deterministic you give me a
state you give me the hamiltonian i
evolve it forward in time okay
there's no puzzle about what the state
will be now
of course we know that in the real world
the noticeable observable
phenomenological
evolution of the wave function is not
deterministic wave functions appear to
collapse
so that's because of a measurement and
to an ever ready into a many worlds
person they say well that's only because
the wave function is branched and you
don't see the whole thing anymore the
whole thing is still deterministic you
just find yourself on a single branch
to other people they will tell other
stories about it okay
but the fact of quantum measurement is
one reason why
the wave function does not appear to
evolve deterministically
but you still can say otherwise except
for measuring
the wave function should evolve
deterministically okay
well that's not true for hawking
radiation for hawking radiation you have
a black hole
okay and it gives off radiation
and what hawking derived in his
formulas is that you cannot
deterministically evolve
from the black hole to the entirely
evaporated black hole so here is poof
black hole went away okay this
rule hawking's rule
to go from a black hole to a gas of
radiation a bunch of photons leaving the
black hole having evaporated completely
away
is not deterministic there is some
randomness
that sneaks in there so you can make the
black hole
let's say you made the black hole out of
collapsing not a star but a whole bunch
of books
don't ask me why you would ever want to
do such a terrible thing but
let's imagine that you have a whole
bunch of books and you've thrown them
into the black hole
you made a black hole out of books
this is deterministic this is the
schrodinger equation but once the
hawking
evaporation happens it is no longer
deterministic
so it seems that if they were writing in
the books
there's information in the books that
information has been destroyed
by the black hole evaporating you cannot
recover it even in principle
and you might say well i destroy
information all the time i take you know
a book and i burn it or something like
that
let's imagine you know burn books on
purpose but by accident maybe there's a
fire in the book burned okay
i've lost the information but according
to the schrodinger equation as long as
no
quantum wave function collapses happened
in principle
even though it would be very hard to
actually recover it the information
contained in the book that you burned is
still there
it's contained in very very subtle
correlations and locations of all the
photons and all the heat and light that
came out and the ash and dust that came
out of the burning okay
whereas here it seems that the
information is once and truly
lost in a more fundamental way
i'm not going to say much more about the
black hole information puzzle than that
it's a good puzzle
the reason why it's hard is because you
might just say well okay
hawking's hawking's derivation was just
incomplete you know he didn't know the
once and for all rules of quantum
gravity
and that's completely fair he didn't it
was kind of a phenomenological thing
it's like the difference between
you know fluid mechanics and the
individual microscopic notions of the
individual atoms hawking was working at
the level of this higher level theory
he didn't claim to have a full theory of
quantum gravity he was just doing
quantum field theory in a curved
background space time
so maybe you can say once we got this
all figured out
then we can see how the information gets
out
that's a perfectly valid ambition to
have and to hope for
it turns out to be really really hard to
get there
in practice and the basic reason why is
it goes back up to these diagrams that
we're drawing right of
you know here we made a black hole out
of a collapsing star
so let's make a black hole and let it
evaporate okay
so instead of a diagram that looks like
this
with the singularity here horizon here
star collapsing here okay so here is
r and t as what we made before
here is the horizon i should just draw
the horizon in a different color
shouldn't i
so so it's visible okay and that's the
singularity
make a singular different color also so
here information loss is no big puzzle i
mean you take a book
and you throw it into the black hole
book
throw it in well i mean it's lost to you
the information that was in the book is
inside the black hole now
but you can convince yourself it's not
lost to the universe it's just inside
the black hole
i can't get there but it still exists
okay
this is what makes hawking's story
puzzling is because
the black hole goes away so you can no
longer say
that the information in the book is in
the black hole and the kinds of
diagrams that we draw in this case i'll
make things simple by not drawing the
star
collapsing anymore here is
the event horizon you know at some point
the event horizon forms
right but then it goes away because
there's hawking radiation that escapes
to infinity the black hole shrinks and
the way people draw the diagram is
the singularity sort of ends at some
point here
and then the
event horizon also ends there and
therefore
this becomes the new origin of
coordinates so this is r equals zero
here and this is r equals zero
here it got shifted over to the right
but that's just a way of drawing
and the black hole is just this area
right here it sort of came into
existence for a finite time it
evaporated away
okay fine all well and good
information is getting out like that but
the problem is now if i throw the book
let me draw the book in a different
color sorry about all the different
colors so here's a book
i'm not going to draw all the pages
anymore but i throw the book in here
and remember we said once you cross the
event horizon nothing crazy happens
right you're just in the black hole so
you can go all the way to the
singularity and then be smooshed in the
singularity
okay if nothing crazy happens when you
cross the event horizon
the book doesn't get erased or the
information in the book doesn't get
transferred to the hawking radiation the
book doesn't even notice the book just
goes right through the event horizon
okay until it smashes through
the singularity and we mentioned you
know i don't say all these things just
for my health we mentioned
that the singularity is a space-like
surface
so if the information in the black hole
can get to the singularity
without being copied there's a theorem
by the way in quantum mechanics that you
cannot
copy quantum mechanical information with
perfect fidelity
so it can't be copied the information in
the in the book is not somehow
photocopied onto the hawking radiation
that's not what happens
the information cannot get from this
point where the book hits the
singularity to the outside world without
moving past
the speed of light there is no space for
it to travel in
because the singularity is the end of
the universe
so if you want to come up with some more
complicated more sophisticated
uh fuller and and more rigorously true
laws of nature that are including
quantum mechanics and gravity
and explain why the information gets out
of the black hole then good for you
let's try to do that
but it seems from the picture that it
will require
super luminal trans transfer translation
transmission super luminal transmission
of that information it will have to
leave
the black hole faster than the speed of
light or somehow there's non-locality
there is some kind of new spooky action
at a distance remember
isaac newton had his spooky action at a
distance because he had two planets
that were gravitationally pulling on
each other and then we said well there's
really a gravitational field in between
so we can explain that
einstein had his spooky action at a
distance where
two entangled particles could be
observed very far away and the
measurement outcome of one would affect
the other but we realize that no
information can be
transmitted this way it seems here
that information has to travel faster
than the speed of light to get outside
the black hole if information is truly
going to be
preserved now one of the leading ideas
right now
is that that's kind of what happens you
know at some point
you bite the bullet that really secretly
there's a microscopic wormhole
connecting what's going on inside the
horizon or what's going on outside and
somehow
that doesn't lead to like large aliens
traveling from inside the black hole to
us
but it affects the character of the
hawking radiation coming out
is this true who knows we don't know but
this is a very exciting like
honestly since the 1990s some of the
brightest theoretical physicists in the
world have been trying to figure out how
to get the information
out of an evaporating black hole we
still don't know for sure
but a lot of good work has been done uh
inspired by this you know that's what we
have
you know when i when hawking passed away
for a while ago um
i was asked to write a piece for the new
york times you know
not an obituary or a biography but an
appreciation like what did he do what is
hawking's greatest gift
to us and hawking as a scientist and
hawking did a lot of
cool things right um hawking uh you know
the area theorem
right um hawking radiation hawking
entropy but in
some sense the black hole information
problem
puzzle some people call it a paradox but
it's not a paradox it's a puzzle
um that's his greatest gift because
that's a puzzle
you know we don't have a lot of
experimental puzzles in quantum gravity
so
a thought experiment puzzle to think
about and improve our knowledge of what
might be going on to act as a guide
to the once and for all theory of
quantum gravity that's one of the
greatest things you can give to the
scientific community and
that's what hawking did that's why he
was kind of a big deal